sometimes you ever to send a rogan and
you feel like he's talking to you like
he'll be criticizing someone or
something up and your likes you be like
wait is he talking about me I know he's
talking about Crona hot guy and he's
like so who needs to be concerned and
he's like the guy goes no people with an
unhealthy diet people that are obese you
know Pete and Joe goes people who drink
a lot and I'm going hey off me he goes
now if you look unhealthy diet don't
really work out they drink too much they
don't sleep enough and I'm like these
are all things I've been taxing with
Joel not sleeping a lot we're good
taught you workout all one time he said
they'll sound that Rogan said this he
was talking around white and I never
talked about this but it was just such a
weird thing he goes like this he goes
yeah I mean acting is so different than
stand up and it court forces you to
compromise yourself Bryan Callen Mike my
good friend Bryan count is auditioning
ruined him it just ruined him because he
had to like squeeze everybody when he's
in the auditions it just ruined me
ruined me I mean I was so weirdest
[ __ ] and Rob White's kept talking
about something else you're not back up
and he's everybody here drinks too much
doesn't work hard enough has no
discipline yeah yeah crazy too I but no
but not those like I don't have Rogan
discipline I have like good discipline
for a guy who's like a high functioning
overall that's like Rogan one time when
I talked to Nick DiPaolo look at Brogan
young man and he goes he goes look at
him look at this forms it's like a
little he's like a ball of hate oh yeah
he goes he's a veiny ball of hate I go
yeah I think goes hey Joe when you don't
work out and before you could get that
sentence out roadless I've never not
worked out I've never questioned his
mood it was just a different animal he's
always been the most intense person he
smokes weed okay you guys met him you've
known him he's been a whoa hothead I
knew him when he was 28 27 26
you have no idea did you go did you ever
open for him Bert no no
I wish I wanted to I'm home I've got a
fly I've got to do press the all day
this is this is last weekend
this is last week I'm home for I'm home
for like [ __ ] two a day I get I'm
home for 24 hours right
like I fly home I flew somewhere to do
press I fly home or I stayed in New York
to depress fly home I'm literally at 24
hours home and my daughter Stewart sick
this will dude like this has been a fun
[ __ ] podcast I haven't talked like
this at all she goes hey I got a I got a
late start tomorrow and I go cool she
goes maybe like we could like hang out
in the morning before school and I go oh
yeah yeah definitely
she was like okay so like what do you
wanna do and I said what do you want to
do and she goes hey anything you want
that I just what just hang out with you
and so I was like okay so we go out that
night with friends and we all have
drinks we have a great time we come home
and I don't even really remember the
conversation I'm laying in bed it's like
7:00 in the morning and I feel the
sensation someone's staring at me and
she's standing over me and she's got
something in her hand she goes hey dad
and I was like what's up she goes I made
you a breakfast sandwich I said you did
she goes yeah I thought we could eat
breakfast together and I was like oh
thanks baby so I get up and I take the
breakfast sandwich out and I sit down at
our breakfast table and I open it and I
said where's yours and she goes I'm not
hungry and I go you just made a sandwich
for me
she was right no you'd want a breakfast
sandwich I made the eggs the way you
want them and I said really she goes
yeah like a little runny and I put some
cheese a little hot sauce I hope you
like it
this little kid made a [ __ ] sandwich
for me so that I would sit and eat it
she wasn't even hungry and I just sat
there and I was like do you want to talk
about where you go she doesn't keep my
daughter don't give a [ __ ] on my special
she like kid give two shits about my
special but she made me a [ __ ]
sandwich and by the way I'm you know I'm
hungover I'm wolf another sandwich now
if I throw it you know I'm just like I'm
like happy doing what she's like like I
just want to sit and talk with you
this weekend I said New Orleans and she
was like oh cool what's like New Orleans
like just picking my brain like a 15
year old yeah and I was like god damn it
man I was I was so like emotional about
that that I was like that I was like
pushed my flight back we're taking the
late flight out to New Orleans tonight
[ __ ] let's go to dinner like let's
hang out I drove to pick her up her
softball talked in the car it was like
it man those moments my business my
biggest fear is losing connection with
my kids and it happens all the time to
people and it happens with a lot of I
know a lot of people who have done very
well in this business who paid that
price st. work I've seen it a lot when
actors and I've seen it it's not she's
you know she's worried cuz you know
whenever I do standby drink well pop it
to stand up when he's in LA damn near
every night and then I go on the road
Thursday to Sunday so I'm sure you've
been a little excessive playing love
your whiskey I love it and you drink
that drink tonight no suicide on on a
Friday night when you've got two shows
yes a whole bottle you drink
burnt and they send out on me you drink
a whole bottle of 250 pounds pop now
you're a big kid I'm trying to be like
oh wait so you know I'm not really drunk
at all I wake up not with a hangover I
worked out dude do it again Saturday
night
yes and then you probably drink
something on something I don't drink on
Sunday I'm not where I want so I won't
drink Sunday when I'm home won't drink
Monday come to stamp on my dad take
Sunday Monday off Tuesday I'm at the
store I drink it the store I have a
double can I have a double
and then Wednesday you know laughs that
you asked me to do it so I'm gonna have
a [ __ ] double dare return the
Thursday I'm back on the road he has a
bottle it's Thursday the fries are the
bottle
Saturday to the bottle so we have
problems without we're problem I'll see
you I don't I don't I don't ski I like I
enjoy it and I don't have I was this way
with wine and now I'm sort of nicotine
bats - do you want some - so I hope that
would create them whatever yeah so you
have a drug your drug addict but then
alcohol but but um like I think for me
what
as I get older hopefully fine yeah me
working out for me I don't like bread
want anymore I don't like it oh how
[ __ ] up is that not crazy I love it
too at night and I in the hot tub oh
don't get me tried before yo trunks
attend a [ __ ] bob of Merlot bro
trucked oh my balls floating up to the
top bottle Oh pop I'll hot them a bottle
of Merlot on a treadmill watching diners
drive-ins and dives his [ __ ]
treadmill red wine everyone everywhere a
treadmill all over on my treadmill and
just [ __ ] jog it dude it's the
greatest thing either right so you start
walking you walking like a 4 right it's
getting windy and you're like wow I
could do this all day here like I could
definitely do this with a glass of wine
right it's like a wine tour almost but
not relatable so I turn on guy's grocery
games and then you start getting buzzed
and your brain will be like [ __ ] it
let's run and you're like now you're
sweating aggressively you get off get
into the sauna get into the pool get in
bed you've worked all those calories all
that's light dude that's like did at one
time at the same time you're getting
drunk while you're doing while you're on
the treadmill I'm sorry
hi I'm the peloton if you're morning Oh
what do you mean what do you mean I'm
balls deep and nicotine high as [ __ ] Oh
rocket team what do you got oh I know
what do you got this is fascinating
oh I kinder I'm a square huh I'm a
little square go ahead I'm more on the
burt spectrum here I'm telling you man I
there's I think when we used to play
baseball you put a dip in and I could
run laughs if you like hey time to do
player appreciations throw a dip in oh I
could do it it's proven that helps with
cardio what you doing cat
lighting up some candles I am so sorry
I've been buying Brendon a bunch of
pastries for his birthday this week yeah
so sorry to your diet
I know you're carnivore well oh that's
how it goes tell girls let's go let's go
hope it doesn't burn out
I guess also seen one getting our happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday
nice
[Applause]
you're 37 happy [ __ ] birthday whiskey
and all
[Laughter]
you're the best
I am so sorry to hear a diet I know this
week's gonna be hell I know I was like
dude he'd be happy he's only lived in
Denver's entire life me oh yeah that's
us that's me but such [ __ ] a thousand
years ago i zoom in who the [ __ ] is that
how was that me and what's with my beard
and what's that shirt I'm wearing that's
all a disaster no I don't mind the
outfit and remember we got the leaky cat
remember we got the shoes from Gucci
that you never will right mmm oh yeah I
tried him off yeah I got a surefire dogs
[ __ ] fire fire I was wearing my those
are common projects I look cute there
but I got a I got to dye my beard
obviously chin Chin's bigger than
everyone in that picture I'm closer to
the camera she looks making gay China my
dad my brother looked the best you Brian
look like [ __ ] has announced that there
is a huge spike in views and they
actually also have this program where
they're allowing people in Italy to use
pornhub premium for free for the rest of
the month
yeah and there has been a huge spike in
views in Italy how about how have you
know I've watched this he's all done
here right have you watched porn you
don't let along I don't I just not done
I don't even think about it itself think
about it but not a ton no but a lot of
people watch it I just it's like this
now I'm gonna now that you watch it I
might watch it tonight
I don't watch as much anymore yeah yeah
you got a girl yeah a plus it just
changes your frickin body you used to
watch it a lot it changes your body like
you know we'd have a girlfriend you
gonna you're gonna jack off on your own
for sure all right yeah and then you're
gonna watch porn yeah but then I like
then your your brain is like adjust to
porn as a turn eyes weird I know there
you got Jane there I Spit on my day
yeah little [ __ ] ass like what Oh
choke on it well Jesus Christ miss your
mind my friend comes over
oh is it a pizza man Oh what's this you
know you're in prison for rape
and hungry yeah pornos [ __ ] things
out dude girl Z I compete with that [ __ ]
look at that look at the spike in March
yeah March the 3rd 4th 5th they Dave
people we're talking about potentially
quarantine is when the views just went
through the roof crazy is that look at
that and apparently there's a lot of
searches for coronavirus on there too
like a lot of people are specifically
looking or learning the rotavirus porn
people are so weird
Tai Lopez Norah Tai Lopez you know a guy
the book day yeah take people out of him
now do you die take your life dude pass
away yeah I was think people died 10
billion dollar giveaway go look at
Stewart Oh what the hell yeah it's 204
pounds I stayed for a load there's no
way huh sometimes you're bored sometimes
you know whatever message you're pushing
is not going well so you need something
to do so you inject a [ __ ] ton of
steroids in your body it looks like
Ludacris from that music video let's see
let's see their body Susie
this one yeah yes say Zack who should I
give this $10,000 to me always me don't
follow everybody I follow given away
$10,000 this month follow everybody that
I'm following on Instagram and pick two
winners a day 500 bucks each you can't
that's wow I don't know
there you go your life stop boys okay
what is back up our chest is 48 that's
awesome bro
his body looked a little odd too right
I thought it looked that way better when
your skin yeah yeah like right there he
looks longer you know the-- I like Jared
Leto better what else you got
that's it I don't know maybe he's doing
it and uh I'll write a book to promote
it when you see my back ripple and I
pull myself up like a champ like a chimp
through 30 times fast while talking to
you why wouldn't I give that to you as
it's a gif it's a gift it's a gift